Uh, 0,
sorry Fabien,
That's great.
In fact,
the right one,
the address for all,
0,
0 ha ha ha ha,
uh,
they exist.
Ha ha.
I'll put,
uh.
1,
1 small,
uh 0.5/10.
So that,
I think it will be one
of the first
measures to implement
when we take the power.
So 10/10.
So uh.
0 and uh.
We support Ukraine here.
0,
that's a lot of 0s.
But actually,
uh.
The following ones don't have much of a place.
And uh.
I'm super happy,
uh.
That the result of the vote in Paris,
then it's 1,
10 because. He has,
he has conf penis and in fact,
he fights against big industry.
So 10/10.
Bah 0,
yeah,
there is 1 virgin,
ha
ha.
So uh.
It can be at 9×10,
but you really have to go and vote.
There is the extreme right which is at 30%.
Move to 1 Europe of social justice,
of climate justice.
Let's go.